the reason i chose ceolo is because they
are introducing a new market category to
the world that is a combination of
gaming and commerce
meaning uh we call it in-game purchasing
platform or in-game purchasing space
where you can purchase physical products
real-life products while you play in
mobile games
um this is also this is a launch of a
product and a brand and a new market
category to the world
and for me it was you know it was a
no-brainer right
in the sense that it's a huge marketing
challenge and one that i felt that i can
uh take upon myself and did it with uh
with the rest of the marketing team
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today with me is adi itach chief
marketing officer of sayolo adi has more
than 10 years of end-to-end marketing
experience in b2c and btc in some of the
leading companies in israel and is now a
leading global chief marketing officer
at sayolo adi is also a business and
marketing consultant to startups from
north america and europe and has her own
podcast called gluten free marketing
where she connects business strategy and
spirituality her strengths are strategic
creative thinking demand generation
brand building strategic business
development startup scaling and creating
high impact multi-channel global
campaigns
all right adita welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you today
thank you i'm very good how are you
i'm doing great i'm so excited to talk
about end-to-end marketing and you know
looking at marketing is a holistic
process uh you know your outlook on
marketing you've held incredible
marketing positions that and the most
incredible
companies in israel and right now in an
emerging startup in the generations in
gaming space so so we'll have to talk a
little bit about this transition because
it's fascinating and but but just as
fascinating yeah a fun fact about you
you were an officer in the idf in the
paratroopers grade and you were one of
the first swimming to do a full yearly
reserve service in a combat unit
and you did it for 16 years right that's
crazy yeah exactly yeah
it really is crazy exactly actually at
the end of this month uh there's a
farewell event yeah and i get my plaque
and i tell idf goodbye for good but yeah
it's been a crazy 16 years
i've really enjoyed myself i've learned
a lot
and most importantly i got to do my
service with
an amazing group of
women and men
that
that have you know the best intentions
at heart and the best commitment to the
country and i absolutely loved going in
every time for this
even though it was super incredible you
know
incredible so really you're you're a
combat fighter behind the behind the the
marketer and the the enemy knife a
podcast of gluten free marketing
yeah
um so yeah i mean
um
i i take my approach i take my
innovative approach to everywhere i go
so yeah try to
to clear the path for others well
well let's dig deep into your you know
your marketing background and your a
little bit about your career and and
what i'd love to understand is you know
your marketing approach your your your
end-to-end marketing thinking style you
know in relation to the things that
you've done and the different
experiences you've had so maybe share
with me a little bit about your
perspective on marketing and then we'll
dive deep into some specific case
studies about that
okay sure
um so i think marketing my marketing
philosophy actually is that marketing is
the north star of the company
is the leading wind or the wind beneath
the wings of the company it has to be 10
steps ahead of everything else
and it has a special location that you
know gives you an inside and outside or
look on things and the market and the
company the product etc
i think that
in order to do a good marketing you you
have to have
an holistic point of view like a 360
view
of everything
i mean you can mix your user acquisition
retention brand
efforts
to that but it has to be done on all
levels you cannot focus on one niche
otherwise you miss other niches and this
is the approach that i've developed in
my career
throughout the 10 years of my experience
a lot of people always ask me what is
your strength
and i say my strength is end-to-end it
sounds funny maybe but it's not because
when you have an end-to-end point of
view you can you can be very creative
you can be you can be very strategic
about how you go and do your marketing
and you can have the best results
in the long run not in the short run and
i believe in working for the long run
because marketing is not a magic
obviously marketing is a strategy
marketing is a creative process
marketing is a fluid kind of a thing
that goes
in and out all the time and you have to
you have to keep going and you know
stick to the strategy and you have to
maintain a 360 view to that
user acquisition is very technical very
measurable retention has its strengths
and brand marketing and product
marketing have a lot to do with both of
them but if you don't connect all the
dots then you're missing out on
something bigger than just you know the
niche that you work on on the channel
that you invest in how does this
translate you know to reality and
practicality because at the end you're
sitting down and you know you have to
market a product how do you know
how much to say you know 30 000 feet in
the air and look at it as an end-to-end
approach versus now going deep into okay
now this is what i have to market right
now for this campaign for this week how
do you balance those two
so this is an excellent question and
this is the the biggest challenge that a
marketeer has you know from from a
bird's point of view to the little
details on the ground right
yeah exactly and so it's it's a it's a
it's a kind of a it's a journey up and
down
and the key is not to get stuck neither
on the bird's view point of view or
uh you know at the little details and
you and the secret sauce is or the
secreting good ingredient is the
flexibility
it's like a muscle that you develop
along the ears
that allows you to go up and down this
um
this i don't know elevator we would call
it maybe
um and
not get stuck
and
the reason
the the the main thing the main tool
that helps me achieve that is the
sticking to the strategy and the vision
of the marketing and of the company
once i know where i'm going or what my
direction might be
i'm more able to you know take better
decisions
with the little details
and you know
for the long run also so it's a balance
a delicate balance between those two and
it's taken me a long time to learn how
to do that and i'm still learning right
i mean this is what i love about
marketing it's an endless process of
creativity
you always learn you always
you can be very curious you can
you can think you know something but you
don't
and a lot of deep diving goes into that
and i love that because i'm a very
self-taught kind of a person
so
um
to answer your question it's a delicate
balance and
it's a delicate dance
i mean does this at the end translate
specifically for example when you're
doing both b2c and b2b marketing forget
you know it's not i i haven't met many
people that are doing both the b2c and
the b2b side because it requires you
know often in my mind it requires two
different products or different
marketing styles two different languages
yet you're looking at this as one
holistic approach of how is get
positioned in its world right
yeah exactly i mean in get we had a
saying that it's b to b and b to c but
it's also p to p
people to people and i really love and
and you know connect to that approach
because
be the beers are also people at the end
of the day right they are b2c in one
product and a b to b in another but
they're people so maybe the positioning
and the messaging are a bit different
but essentially and eventually you're
talking to people
and
when you remember that then the balance
between the b to c the b to b
uh becomes more uh
more tangible and more clear to you
and so at the end of the day you're
selling maybe
different features different products
but it's the same target audience
in the sense that they are people and
you're talking to people and you have to
be understandable and you have to
resonate with them and that's it
i mean
different tools different channels
obviously
to people
yeah
share with me your
transition
from a company like get
to a comp to a startup company
generation z gaming
very very different you know almost
polar opposites and a lot of them in a
lot of senses but you know taking
executive marketing positions in both
you know walk me through that process
for you how do you go about making that
decision
and you know how is that experience like
okay so um the the decision to to move
to a startup
um
was a decision that i made because i
felt like that this is what this is this
was my next
step in my um professional evolution
right
i'm a person that always loved to learn
and do
things differently
and i felt that i needed to take my 10
years of experience and put it into a
startup the reason i chose ceolo is
because they are introducing a new
market category to the world that is a
combination of gaming and commerce
meaning
we call it in-game purchasing platform
or in-game purchasing space where you
can purchase physical products real life
products while you play in mobile games
um this is als this is a launch of a
product and a brand and a new market
category to the world and for me it was
you know it was a no-brainer right
in the sense that it's a huge marketing
challenge and one that i felt that i can
take upon myself and did it with with
the rest of the marketing team
and with the company with the company's
management and for me it was not a
smooth transition because i had to learn
a lot about gaming and gen z marketing
and trust me i thought i knew everything
i had to know about gen z marketing you
know influencers tick tock
absolutely not i mean it's a whole
different ballgame they are a completely
different generation they have
different standards different values
different outlook on life and i really
had and i am still learning this target
audience because they are our end users
right
and i really had to learn them and learn
about them and make my entire marketing
strategy focused on them
whether it's creative whether it's
content whether it's you know how the
product looks like we just launched an
avatar a really cool avatar and we just
launched uh
we tried to decide internally of the
name for the time we had a contact
between the employees and we couldn't
decide because we had a lot of really
good cool names so we pull it out there
on social media for jen's ears to decide
uh how they want our avatar to be called
and so everything i thought i knew
everything i thought i knew about
marketing about gen z marketing i'm
relearning it re-evaluating it and
discovering that it's uh it's a it's an
entirely different situation than i
thought
um and this is what i'm talking about
that marketing is endless because you
get to learn and relearn as you go
and
you have to stay flexible and you have
to stay open-minded and i have to say
that in the few months that i've been in
sayolo my consciousness has expanded so
much and i had to change my mindset and
shift it to a different direction all
together try to imagine that we're
trying to build a marketplace of demand
and supply of dtc brands and publishers
all the while trying to resonate with
gen z
trying to launch a new market category
trying to do product market feed
validation
penetrating the us market
it's a lot of challenges in challenges
in so little time
and it required me to to think different
to act different even my marketing plan
that i structured
was completely different than everything
i ever done before in my 10 years of
experience so
and this is what i love about marketing
because i feel the shift inside of my
channel
yeah i i don't think i've heard uh you
know my consciousness has expanded you
know in relation to to something like
this and i think that that is something
that i'll be taking with me from this
conversation
where do you find your joy
in what you do where where is the joy in
the day-to-day or the the month to month
in in your position as an in executive
marketing
um there are a lot of things that i uh
take pleasure in um
first of all the first thing that comes
to mind is my employees in my team
when they're happy when they're
getting you know my my job is to let
them to to have the space to be as
creative as possible
and then when they get creative and get
confident and you know bring out ideas
and initiatives and enjoy themselves i
enjoy
myself as well because i'm letting other
people you know be creative
and
you know creating a creative space
is very difficult
uh especially when you're trying to do
it you know day after day after day and
for me that's the greatest joy
i also enjoy you know the little
outcomes the little reactions from
customers
uh on social media on the product
and obviously results right we're all um
results driven so when i see in the long
run that my strategy and my marketing
efforts are fruitful then that gives me
also a big pleasure but
it all comes from within and if i and if
i feel that
i bring my a game and i evolve and
i get to bring a d to the marketing
efforts whatever it's it may be then
this is my joyous moment and i work hard
for those moments because it's not fun
all the time obviously
it takes a lot of hard work i'm sure
i'm i'm positive and and now you know
sort of the
the peril to this you know you have to
be
you're mentioning creativity your
consciousness needs to expand the way
that you're approaching problems now
with generations is different than the
way that you've thought about them
before and the way that you're learning
things it sounds like it's also shifting
and
expanding where do you get the
inspiration to even know you know
whether you're doing the right thing
whether you're thinking the right way
about something maybe you know that
you're going into these creative
into these creative projects
where do you get all this inspiration
from
so um inspiration comes from within
so i try to tap into my inner
creative places
i listen to music and
i
love going to the beach
i live in michomot uh which is a quiet
place uh
a quiet place a city
not a city but a
small place by the beach and it has an
amazing beach an amazing sea and i love
the depth of the sea and the colors
it inspires and brings out you know a
really
uh a real joy inside of me i take
inspiration in great leaders and great
friends that live their lives the way i
want to live my life
and at the end of the day uh you asked
how i make sure that what i'm doing is
you know
is resonating
i is that i
directly
connect with my target audience
when i had to learn all about gen z
marketing i did zoomed
and um
you know um
live uh focus groups
with gen zers
for example i had to call my cousin and
he's 17 and i told him bring 10 of your
friends this is going to be pizza we're
going to talk about gaming right
um and i've learned a lot just by
sitting with them
and because i don't believe in doing
marketing you know from uh 30 000 feet
i have to know my target audience and
after that i did a focus group for
american gen xers
um with uh help of a few friends from
united states
and i've learned a lot about them as
well and the differences between the
israeli ones and the american ones but
you know they all have common
denominators and i took those common
denominators and i developed them
and i still meet with those two focus
groups
when they have time for me because jen's
ears are not
pleasers right they do what they do if
they have time they'll give you their
time if they're not they're not they get
bored very easily so you know and those
things were pretty hard for me because
i'm a boomer i'm not ashamed to call
myself that i'm a gen y
and we had values or we thought we had
values and depth and
and when i sat down with them i was like
they have no values but actually they do
but they're just different values
they're very transparent
they're very gender neutral
they believe in equality
they're very diverse
and they're very unique in their own way
and i love that because when i was
growing up everyone tried to be
the same
and they are not afraid to be different
and that's very inspiring also
an incredible and if you had to think of
a few words
a few words that
that you would use to describe yourself
or if i were to ask anybody you know
around you who is adi
what words would you use
um
okay um so this is the question what i
when i have to say that um it's pretty
it's difficult to talk about myself but
um if i'm being honest creative is the
first word that comes to mind
loving is the second one
um
and
a leader is the third one
i think well that you know come to the
wrong show and uh and i find so much
inspiration from you know from your your
leadership but uh you know leadership in
the sense also of just the thinking
process and the the
expansion of the consciousness as you've
said it and the way that you're drawing
inspiration from change and from you
know the complexity of situations and
understanding that that sometimes the
holistic approach is the cor is is you
know the right way to think about things
because there's no you know in today's
world there's no bucketing everything is
connected and at the end
i i the way that you're looking at
marketing i think just really opened my
eyes to to the way that i look at
marketing and so i really appreciate
your time and your energy
and thank you very very much again and
uh
thank you for joining
thank you for having me so much